Afonso from an editor's point of view
what makes a great actor a great actor
for me it's somebody that reacts and
somebody that can reacts to the moment
reacts to another actor reacts to the
text so it's somebody that doesn't come
I mean of course the actors can prepare
they know what's going on but somebody
just sorta like can adjust to the moment
and I could like react accordingly you
know this room was interesting because
with with with Cate and Rooney they were
great at Carol Kate would try something
and Rooney would just follow suit and
just go with that
so Todd could give directions to change
the directions to either one of the
actors and the other actor would react
to it and I think that makes it a good
it's somebody that listens
basically yeah and I think that makes a
great great actor how closely are you
working with a script when you're
editing a film well I use this usually
what I do I read the script and then
when the footage is come in and I cut
the scene as they they are and when I do
my first pass the first assembly then
sometimes I read the script again and
just just to have an ideas like okay
this may not be exactly the way it is
but it's close to the script is close to
that don't take anything out in the
first pass and then once thought comes
in or whatever the writer comes in so in
this case when Todd came in then you
kind of leave this the script and you
have to create the world base and what
he shot which is a little bit different
from from the original script so how
often do you see that with feature films
where the movie takes a different shape
from the script once you get it in post
I mean I think it happens often in the
films that I not really like I don't
have relationship I don't know but the
films that I work most times you eat
changes it definitely it's it there's a
leap and there's some the differences
it's it's noticeable because you
just once they're shooting something
else interesting enough that film that
the closest was in the film and the
meaning the HBO miniseries is what I did
with Todd I think was the closest thing
that I've ever done that we almost
didn't change anything it was like to
the T exactly the way was in the script
which is kind of like fascinating and I
don't know why it was just happened to
be that way but it was like a five and a
half hour piece any was just two things
so we've kind of shifted around the rest
was just like as is and I didn't know
that I only knew knew that because
afterwards after the whole thing was
something that I went back and read the
script it was like wow that's kind of
amazing how little we was shifted at
what point do you sign on to a movie in
most cases he depends I think now I'd
rather sign on from from the very
beginning even from the script stage so
if the directors that worked before like
with with Todd or all the directors that
I had a chance to work before I die they
send me the script and I talk about the
script in a sort of if they want really
specific ideas I'll give them ideas or
just read descriptions like this is
great or and from then on getting Paul
but sometimes or it could be the first
first time we work when the person I
would still love to get involved at
least in be cutting while they're
shooting because then you can give them
or you can give them feedback just just
as as close as possible and as much as
possible as an editor I want to be there
and want to be involved they want to
just just be part of the of the creative
process so they're giving you dailies
and then you're going in and sort of
shaping that scene yeah okay on Carol
they were shooting in Cincinnati my
cutting wound was in New York City so
they were so they were shooting one day
they were shifted the scene that the
negative there was really super 16 so
the negatives come to New York they got
scanned to 4k gets my cutting room and I
will cut and Todd doesn't like to watch
dailies it just does not watch daily so
I would watch the footage and I would
just give him feedback he their email
text or be like okay this is this is
great the show and because it was being
shot in super 16 so there are things
that you
see anymore sore if there was any
scratch the negative if there was like
soft pokers if there was hair in the
gate and stuff like oh those were film
things that you have to pay attention
out of that on Carol so that's what I
was doing and then I would just assemble
as it came in what I was seeing I got
that day I cut that scene and I cut the
whole film that day that cut the whole
film when it was finished shooting and
then Todd came in after he shot he took
a little break he came back did very
detailed notes shot sat by himself
watching the whole the footage took
detail notes gave it to me and then I
cut the film based on the notes so and
then he came in and we start working
together that way how common is that for
a director not one to not want to see
the dailies and why what is the logic
behind that I'm not really sure the
logic behind for Todd I think he just
doesn't want to get you into his head
about how things are working he wants to
focus on building that world as he's
directing and creating the visual world
in every possible way no in the
photography but with production design
and constant design and everything so he
wants to be Merson that world not to be
thinking how's this gonna cut here this
is it here so it kind of is trusting me
to be okay you got it so just keep doing
it I think that there are directors that
there the few directors they actually
don't want to don't want to see anything
but most of the times they want to take
a look even they ask and it's gonna do
can kind of sync together Kenny as it's
going there were they're very
interesting to know how is shaping up
I'm sure there's different ones that
want to be right there with you at all
times and then others that give you a
lot of freedoms yeah I like to have the
director in the room with me as much as
possible I really do because I think
that the dialogue and how are you you're
building and creating creating the
scenes we talk talk talking then I can
do something on the avid any of you can
put it just on the side now looking at
me work but doing something else and
then I can just right away be like okay
how about this
okay I have an idea how about this so I
think there's a fluidity to have the
director there and then just and I think
he's stimulating too because I can if
the director is not there and I
understand sometimes directors just
bored
- to be in the cutting room because
watching somebody cut is not it's not
that easy because it's such an internal
process but I like that you you being
like you fire is always been stoked in a
way because you're always having that
conversation if the director leaves and
I've done something I had to wait for
him to come back sometimes it's just
sort of like it's too much of a the then
the flow may just be too slow so having
him around and Todd and I know Todd
likes to be in the cutting room so it
sits perfectly was great
is there anyone else that comes into the
cutting room as well is it just the
director it's just a director I mean
unless he even fights I think ad came in
a couple of times and while I was
cutting and Todd wasn't around and and I
had a thought it's okay to show stuff to
add in Todd says of course you can come
in and but we don't my assistant it's
another it's the person that I showed
the cards and I want to feed like
immediate feedback I come from my
assistant and then it's something like
if Christine would come in or I'd she
she never does or we want to show people
we do but most of the time is just just
us just the two of us building it like
finish it out that way do you choose an
editing style before you begin cutting
or is that something that evolves over
the film and working with the director
absolutely I don't so I think it's a it
would be a mistake it felt like I know
how I'm gonna do this hey I don't know I
actually I always part from the the
premise that when I'm gonna cut the film
I don't know how I'm gonna cut this film
at all I have no idea in a good way now
like her I don't like it but it's just I
just want to be informed by the footage
I don't be like oh this is gonna be you
know it's Todd Haynes or is whatever is
Jim Jim Jarmusch I know that I'm working
with them but I'd rather just understand
what what the footage is and then you
can talk and when you have the dialogue
be like oh this is how it's gonna be
this way this way and you kind of inform
and you're important not only by the
footage but but the dialogue but I don't
bring any preconceived like ideas or
notions or how this is gonna be exist
wire cuts faster these days like I look
at like let's say dinner with Andre
versus you know the Bourne Identity or
even beyond that and things have
definitely sped up yeah and and and
scenes are shorter and there and them
it's cut much faster what do you think
that is I think I'd be part of it I
think a little bit as impatience from
the part of the audience but I think a
lot of it is because the honesty is is
more people watched so much now so much
more than ever I think of everything
that there is a level of just the
quality of the viewers are higher they
understand and they perceive and they
they notice things faster that's just
like understanding and and reacting to
the intimate material there's much
faster now than it used to be and this
was actually a little bit of a challenge
with Kara because we knew because it was
a love story and because the way Todd
was directing the actors and because the
way the actors were doing delivering the
lines in-camera there we needed to slow
down we needed to like okay this is not
we needed to we we had to earn the
audience trust that the pace that we
were going for was the right pace I
couldn't be like she talks she talks he
talks he talks he had to be like she
talks she reacts she reacts she talked
like a little bit like that's half a
step slower than you expect some of the
scenes to be it was just something that
we were trying to to to make sure that
that that pace was was the right pace
and then people were kind of like
guiding you through that that kind of
rhythm if that makes sense
it does and I loved it I'm wondering
with a lot of films is there a quicker
cutting and either like book ending the
film or anywhere is in the middle maybe
it's slower or maybe I'm just first yes
it is in and even the the relationship
between people like Tara's with her
boyfriend everything is super it's fast
it's very
she's very directly a sequester she says
no they overlapped a dialogue is
overlapped so there is there's more like
that there's or it's Carol and Abby they
know each other so there's no there's no
need for seduction or different pace or
like it pauses they can just talk
they're talking because they know each
other so it's relationships that kind of
dictate the rhythms and because the very
beginning of the phone the very end of
the film is the exact same scenes not
the very end but the scenes in at the
bar of the hotel in the beginning you
just get half of what was going on so is
the tale and in the end the scene is a
little quicker that Carol comes and sit
down says do you hate me and says no it
is quick no how could I hate you and
then uncomfortable so there is a change
and then as the film that as the scene
progresses it slows down as you saw in
the beginning it's like they re
connecting and they re learning their
risa duck sings like the seduction
happens again so those are the things
that there there has to be contrast to
look in the middle some stuff it's slow
because it's Carol talking to her lawyer
and learning and things like that but
some of the reactions between cars and
Abby it's super confrontation and there
they are step in each other's thought
there and she's like yeah this is
happening he's like slamming the door
she's stopping it's it's he has to be
kind of more nervous because there's
there's tension and there's tension in
holding pauses longer than you expect
you create that sort of anticipation
what's coming next when is coming so
when you get notes to make a cut here
there once you do that edit do you then
go back and watch the whole film again
to see if it works or just that scene
just that scene I mean it eventually
you were so a thing but every time you
do something go back and just like take
so long you just you trust that what
you're doing before it's working up to
this point and then if you want to do
something but you kind of you remember
you have kind of like the pulse of how
things going but
the good thing about editing because it
takes a while to do it and then you can
try & retry and retry and kind of find
that the right balance and the rhythm of
overall this serve he has to be a
musical thing it has to flow in a very
certain way like the whole piece a font
so looking at your IMDB page you have 44
editing credits which include true
detective winners bone and beasts of the
southern wild
you've been editing since 1992 is that
right well that I was a student from
school actually I've been editing since
my first real job was 1996 okay okay so
when would you say you became good at
editing and then when did you transition
to excellent like how many times you
know I don't know that's that's hard to
say I don't know I'm still hoping that
I'm striving for the excellency so I
don't know if I became excellent yet I
think so thank you but I'm I mean I
still love it the same way as that my
first film I truly loved and I started
and I find that every movie that I do
and every director that I work with I'm
learning something and I'm open and just
like feeding somebody like Todd is it's
just incredible it's like a master class
in film and filmmaking in not only not
only there is an aspect of editing -
that's rarely be talked about it's just
it's not only a technical stuff but it's
it's a social you spend 10 12 hours of
your day every day for six months with a
person so you really have to like this
person and we really enjoy being each
other's company and talk about films and
talk about other things not just the
movie and in those moments you learn and
those moments from do you like he talks
about music and books and and and things
and you just taking notes and films that
he loves and stuff all that so it's I
love that aspect - of being an editor
and being with with somebody like Todd
it's it's it's fantastic but my goal is
to get still achieve more excellency
then then then now and in work keep keep
working in projects like this it's so
kind of
incredible when did you know you had the
temperament to be an editor because
things sounds so great in theory whether
it's an actor and all yeah I want to do
this but then the audition process burns
a lot of people out the rejections go
and then with editing you're also alone
a lot behind the computer a lot
yeah and it's it's very in you need to
be super patient because it is about
repetition it's really about like it's a
very detail-oriented job and and I just
found myself when I was in film school
and I start cutting it's like oh this is
it this is what I love because I can do
the same that I can repeat the same
thing 15 20 30 100 times and I can see
the difference and I'd be like okay I
think this is I find that this is better
than this and you you kind of your body
respond is sort of intuition it's God
I just I like it I love it I'm
interested in and it's just I'm patience
I think and and yeah I think that's
that's what it is I don't know it's like
in a prime name sort of in a practicum
that's what it is on our face I just
have the mind to it yes so you just knew
that this was this because you thought
you could see results you could also be
on your own you know you're getting
notes but you're kind of your own person
while you're making those you know yeah
and makes sense of story like sort of
structurally I can sometimes watch the
stories like okay this somehow if you
like to do it this is this and this is
this and they could do that that way
works and I can I have that kind of
ability to do that somehow so I think
that helps too